this isn't just another trip Neil your
night was going to work do you say no
coming back first man tells the story of
one of the most illustrious men to walk
the earth because he was famously the
very first on the moon
this biopic of Neil Armstrong sheds
fresh light on a man who made history
but whose personal story has been
virtually untold highlighting his family
life and the role played by his wife
Janet it felt like a remarkable story
about fallible human beings thrown into
completely extraordinary circumstances
and trying the best they could and
somehow out of that came this you know
iconic event I was really interested as
to why he wanted to tell the story
because to me I was like you've made
whiplash he made model and then there's
the moon landing but then as soon as he
started talking about it as soon as he
started talking about the idea that
there's a man at the center of it and
and you know the sacrifice of not just
him but his family and and also the idea
of you know going after something
striving for something and it's a
classic case of behind every great man
isn't it it's a great woman and she
clearly was Janet as herself as an
extraordinary person and and was amazing
for me to kind of get to know and
investigate the film has proved somewhat
controversial in the States accused of
being unpatriotic because it doesn't
include the moment the American flag was
planted on the moon are you bothered
that Trump is not gonna come see your
film yeah I was surprised a little bit
by the by all of that you know I it felt
to me like the point of making a movie
about you know such a famous event with
such famous imagery associated with it
would be to not just you know kind of
reproduce that imagery or those events
would be to actually try to look at what
happened in between the untold stories
so you weren't trying to criticize or
offend President Trump no it was it was
not a
it was not a political statement at all
was purely a purely an aesthetic choice
I do think it's interesting that you
know the conversations that are being
had a largely about people who have
actually seen the film at all I just
think people need to go and see it
really we have serious problems so the
president won't be watching but with a
starring role from Her Majesty and a
true story quite literally out of this
world is not likely to matter music
Arthur Sky News